hey everybody welcome back to the DC
stage really come on guys wait we got a
couple of guys here you should be more
excited about my name is Mike Gavilan
i'm with sci-fi wiring is my genuine
pleasure to bring up two legends of
comics here to talk about their latest
project Superman year one john romita
jr. and frank miller john take a seat
I'm Frank I'm sorry that's just done
you'll be putting on a little art
display for us while we talk here Frank
you're gonna supervise and make sure
that he does a good job you're gonna
micromanage is drawing I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry these tools are not good
enough you know it's okay so did I you
know I I'm not a teacher and also uh
there's their lost causes and there's
four meter ball busting 101 on stage all
right it's pretty much sorry if there's
children in the audience let's keep it
clean John there are children here Frank
this is the first time in quite a while
you guys have worked together when you
came up with the idea for the project
was John's name first and you lists of
who you wanted to reach out to to
collaborate with on it you want to
straight you want a straight answer
right you're the do you want total honor
with you it was a long list and he
wasn't honored no actually he was the
only guy I could think of did the idea
of seeing him draw a Superman was was
one of the main things got me going on
this on this project I always wanted you
to Superman but working with John again
made an irresistible project John how
easy was it for you to say yes when he
called you and talked to you about it
every time we talk about working
together I'd say I have yes prepared for
him so it's not a problem it's in the
back pocket waiting for him we grew up
together in the industry so to speak so
we've worked together not enough but the
times that we have have been glorious to
me
but you know you would have to draw
about 200 pages though for these three
years I didn't know it was gonna be
doing wait a minute wait a minute excuse
me it wasn't you made it that long
telling the story about the addendum on
Man Without Fear oh god yeah well a man
without fear that's man without fear the
you know the daredevil oh man without
fear book started really is my treatment
for a TV pilot for a production of
daredevil that never got made and and I
talked to John about making it into a
comic book series and we got rolling but
as we got rolling the page his pages
started coming in and they gave me all
kinds of ideas so I would send him
addenda which was just additional scenes
and sequences to draw in the book well
these venez page who's coming in and
they'd be amazing and they put they
would take up a lot of pages and they
would just inspire all kinds of ideas
more ideas so I'd send some more in
and they came rolling back in this thing
that was supposed to come out as this
little four-issue miniseries just kept
getting fatter and fatter and fatter and
bigger and bigger until it became the
book that you're familiar with and it
was it was really a case of how it was a
really a sign of how things were
starting to loosen up in the industry
and how we could work much more like
novelists too and not not be so trapped
and it got to be the length that really
wanted to be a needed to be and if we
got to get all those a really nice big
full page and double page ramita
drawings that we got in there he said I
have an addendum it's gonna come right
now because but ramita is what we call a
very whiny man he calls me and says
between page 17 and 18 is gonna be an
addendum and just throw it in there it
was 88 pages
so tell that's what happened here only
not quite in between page 17 and 18 what
I'm curious about is you know like the
first issue it's it's gorgeous just
gorgeous pages right but there's not a
hero stuff in there John
in this first issue it's almost all in
Smallville and he's drawing these
amazing pages but it's not you know
superheroes slugging it out in space or
above metropolis that's got to be
challenging and you can obviously speak
to this you're an artist as well are
those kind of sequences harder to draw
for you then the big epic fight scenes
they're challenging but they're not
harder it's just you have to make sure
that they look legit as opposed to
playing with the action choreography so
you have to have somebody walking down
the street of a Kansas towns gotta look
like a Kansas town can't be Manhattan
and yeah they're challenging but we've
done it before so it's kind of fun to
get into it and those instances with him
as a young man with bullies or you know
being awkward with the female playing
football that was more fun than the
choreography the battle scenes tell the
truth
it was he mentioned the scenes with the
female
Lana Lang is awesome in the girls
they're women and he's just females he's
like a guy out of the 50s what do you
what all you males out there tell me
about Lana and your story because in
that first issue she's such a
firecracker and she's so fascinating off
the the page how much fun did you have
writing her in this story I love writing
Lana and and in nate's if Lana and Lois
to me really it's they have to be there
for Superman to work for Clark to work
because because they're there the
powerful characters I mean both are both
are very courageous the Lana is
absolutely fearless in the face of
terrifying taunts and and the Menace of
of the the bad kids and Louis will she's
beyond belief she's you know she's
braver than Superman
and so that the these characters really
define him in many ways he's really
turning into an explorer here he's
learning about his planet as pot Kant
tells him in issue one tell me about how
you approached telling you know filling
in the blanks in this part of Superman's
story because you said something
interesting in an interview when the
when the book debuted he said Batman can
be summed up rather easily
Superman is is a bit harder to do what
did you mean by that and how does that
inform your storytelling approach here
well you can say if you really wanted to
describe Batman to somebody you can say
he saw his parents murdered when he was
a little boy and decided to fight crime
for the rest of his life and that tells
you an awful lot of what you need to
know about Batman was Superman it is
more difficult because you've got to
describe that he was born on a utopia
that was that was that was extinguished
by the hand of God and that he would
that he was you know put in a rocket
like you know like like like Moses cast
upon the sea to to to come to be raised
in in you know Midwestern America and
and and become this American icon so he
is it's you know if it's a more tortured
path in many ways even though he's not
the Dark One I just like the fact is
he's gone through all of this agony he's
seen his entire species wiped out and
he's still got a good attitude well I I
just I I just love the aspect that he
edited us that the Kansas parents
affected him more so than his natural
parents and probably saved the universe
because if they had been maniacs and
turned him into an axe murder we'd had
all been a lot of trouble it's
so the if he if he landed in the wrong
neighborhood in Appalachia they go if he
landed in Brooklyn we'd all been in
trouble
we're not generalizing with the people
in Appalachia but I get your boy no
that's that's a great point and park and
obviously and ma can give him the great
advice that they do it that really helps
shape his character but it's really you
said this that it's it's it's a it's an
immigrant story that you're telling you
and about him learning about this new
land that he that he's living in and
he's going out there and then you excuse
me that is an immigrant story but that
makes it a quintessentially American
story because everybody in this room is
an immigrant and and and and he's so
deep the I mean there's a reason why the
character names Superman isn't a
blond-haired blue-eyed Nordic character
the character was created as they as
World War two was brewing and I believe
there's an element of the create of the
creation of Superman that was a response
to the global fascist movement of the
time that that certainly those two
Jewish kids in Ohio were feeling a lot
of what of the the winds of war that
were coming and so Superman Superman is
a character with cultural significance
and I think Nicky well we can't walk
around parading that in this book we
keep it in our back pockets in the back
of our minds as we do it more
importantly it's he gonna ink this or
I'm gonna redraw this because I'm
looking at it I want to fix everything
that I just did go do you want to you
want to play with this make it look
better like Danny like Danny Mickey did
on old 200-page where's Danny thank him
for saving my ass on that book
keep it clean remember think of the
children like this posterior okay while
he's examining your artwork and getting
ready to rip it to shreds what can we
expect in the upcoming issues under this
story oh wait first Franklin what do you
have to say about it
I was nervous the Sun was in my eyes the
bills the kids you know all that stuff
save it please for their sake I hope
grumbling in the back is this off no one
you would show your dad you know lies my
father would love it my mother would
saying he's dead Jim what do we think
folks do we like that drawing hmm well
pepid tepid applause well we need him to
fix it so on the viewer I mean how long
have you been thinking about doing this
for a living like I said the bills dear
to their schools to teach every time the
mortgage invoice comes in the mail it
gets me in the mood to work what do you
mean what do you believe yes we have
mortgages us normal people but he's
trying to tell me he gets paid for this
oh this is sad I feel like it's just
getting personal I should I almost feel
like I need to walk off the stage here
you know Frank what would you change
about that drawing don't know why now
what drawing I can fix it your
conversations during the the you have no
idea what I've shown girls alike be
crazy what a change is ever me drawing I
wouldn't change a damn thing that's why
we have Danny McKee and Alex Sinclair
great part of the package on this book
by the way real quick you and you
enlisted Clark in the Navy and there's a
big change you know I know the book is
technically out of continuity but why
was that an important part of the story
well the idea there and it was not it
was not my idea
was was but was that it was the was that
puck and would say to Clark are you
gonna say this planet you got to know it
you got it you got a you got a uh uni
but you really got it cutting no you got
to see it you got to see the people you
got to get a better sense of how it
works and and so it began the beginning
of his exploration of what his mission
was and of a shape of so that he wasn't
just out to defend a small town or a
single metropolis or a single country
that he would that he would that he
would be a global superhero and so and
so so this was a way way to get him
involved in in seeing the world also
along the way it gets him to get him to
put him it puts him in life in death
situations where he gets tested in ways
that that he otherwise wouldn't have
been tested you know he's he's income
life threatening combat situations but
he has an absolute code that he was
taught by the Kent's not to not to
murder and so all of this gets put to
the test in his it's a right he has to
go through before he begins his life in
Metropolis but imagine that conversation
with a intergalactic super person I
don't want you to take any [ __ ] from
anybody pardon me but you gotta save
people that are getting it from being
bullied if you don't split that hair
imagine the difference in the character
so if the the Kansas I remember my
father telling me I don't want you
starting the fights I don't want you
hurting anybody but if anybody lays a
hand on you have to break their their
ribs that's how you got to put it and
that imagine telling an intergalactic
super being that that's that's
staggering I love it and if the father
had been a weaker person
he might not have been the superhero
that he is you know Elsa when you think
about it to what we're like what I
really love about it is that you've got
a character who is when you say his
father you mean I can't
you don't mean jor-el like you know it's
a because the one he learns from is is
is is an earth man and from an earth
woman as well and it's it's it's so he's
he's he's very complex character Ernie
that simple sir what's wonderful is when
you have a character who comes from such
complex origins but the result is simple
meaning that from all of these all of
these forces that have affected him and
all these terrible things that have
affected him what emerges is someone who
is good and pure and simple in in in his
intent I you gotta tell us who's the
first of the Superman villains were
gonna meet before this story ends Toyman
it was a tease come on give us a hand
mr. McGee is spittle lik and you give me
a serious answer come on
we really wanted Peter to write a new
Superman villains could stand above all
the rest you gotta understand Batman got
all the goodies you know except two but
Big D but you know Batman guy yeah let's
put it plainly Batman got the Joker
nobody's scarier than him but Superman's
terrestrial enemy is Lex Luthor the guy
who's got nothing on Superman at all
except that he's smarter than Superman
and and but but the but the deadliest
most the deadliest enemy he's got in the
entire universe is the monster that
committed genocide that the one who
destroyed his planet the one that
destroys planets and actually kidnaps
entire cities and puts them in in jars
so the the big ones Brainiac that's
gonna be cool just gave it away you
didn't hear that
you didn't hear it you didn't hear by
the way what you're gonna have to wait a
few years for that isn't it nice to
finally put to bed all that nonsense
that Frank Miller didn't like Superman
isn't it nice to definitively put this
up and say see I've always said it for
years I didn't not like Superman Batman
didn't like Superman Batman kicks
Superman's but I mean come on again
whenever he gets the chance no specific
shipper you drew one hundred ninety
pages for this three 190 pages is there
one massive classic romita jr. double
splash a page that we're going to
you know look one night the one that I
like the best is the three characters in
the third issue since you give away the
ending I can say that's a great one the
Superman Batman and Wonder Woman and
they're just about to beat the crap out
of each other she come steps in and it
stops it and I think that moment those
three because I've always wanted to do
all three and I got a chance to draw
Wonder Woman finally that's the first
time you got to draw did well with the
three of them together wow that's
incredible first and make me want to do
the character again because what she
does to the well I'm not gonna give it
too much by the book make him buy the
book but I do want to it's okay let's
see we can say whatever we want because
we are lying
everybody dies in the end that's fine
yeah are we gonna fix this drawing what
we gonna be a fix that so I can talk I
don't know who's better you better
anchor than you are a talker or what
there's no fix in it well he's looking
at that and mulling what he wants to do
no I know what I want to do I want to
get away from that Thanks you're running
out of time you're gonna have to fix
that John I can finish it I'll fix it
when inka in all seriousness it'll mix
in the inks touchy you know you know
that line goes back to before his father
you know fixing the inks Frank by now is
there like a certain shorthand that you
have with John I know in all seriousness
that what you guys are talking through
the book like are you guys in that kind
of rhythm that you can say something
exact or do you guys have to work
through the story in long phone
conversations or it's better than that
it's that Danelle
I'll come up with a bunch of ideas and
talk them over with with John on the
world I'll write down some stuff and
then what comes back is so much better
than what I had in mind that that I'll
just be rewriting stuff like crazy it's
always waiting for the other ballbusting
to happen and there's something more
coming this is too nice you know well it
all sucks but that's the basic dynamic
what he did which is the most fun for an
artist is he gives
to play we discuss it in advance
he gives room to play and then he goes
in and makes it better with dialogue it
was such a comfortable working
relationship that that's why I want to
work with him again he'll it's again we
learned how to tell stories early on
because we were given plots only so we
know this and it works to our advantage
it's so much fun because you get input
from the artist and then he hones it
with dialogue was great it really is the
method that was developed by by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby yes and Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko but particularly Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby where where the the
artist was was that which was the
primary storyteller in terms of figuring
out the pacing and and and the
positioning and including many of the
story elements and the it so that the
the writer would bounce on either side
of the process first first at the plot
level and then coming in to pull the
whole thing together and add the musical
notes of the words with this is
something that this is now this is a
standing Jack made it look easy and it
is easy in the right hands in that it's
pleasurable and it brings the best out
of everybody but you've got to know what
you're doing and you've got to be able
to trust each other
ladies and gentlemen Frank Miller John
Romita Jr thanks live and look at John
is just about done yeah amazing
oh and look a special surprise guest
Danny Mickey yeah right up here come on
up here come on up here why didn't we
have him ink this don't look at this
Danny I bet you can't pencil as well
guys a few minutes tick they're gonna be
on the other side signing for the
wristband sighing so if you have the
wristbands
you'll be over there we have a gift for
this young man in the green outfit the
guy with the beard older than he is you
know what let your Frank's name on it
put your hand [ __ ] on that boss Frank
initial left for our buddy here
beautiful beautiful ma'am it doesn't go
on the bottom of bird cages it's gotta
go
you
you